le Qatar est un des pays les plus riches
au monde avec l'argent du pétrole la
capitale d'oie a émergé du désert pour
devenir une ville
ultra moderne pour accueillir la Coupe
du Monde et remettre plein la vue les
émirs ont investis 220 milliards du
jamais vu la Russie n'avait dépensé que
12 milliards le Brésil 14 milliards
avec un réseau rapide qui va permettre
au spectateur d'éviter les
embouteillages
une toute nouvelle ville a été
construite autour du stade principal
tout est utile stade climatisé hôtel
route station de métro un très rapide
l'envers du décor c'est que ceux qui ont
construit tout cela l'ont fait au péril
de leur vie et de leur santé
[Musique]
au Népal des collègues on retrouve pour
nous certains de ces travailleurs
behrendra a vécu au Qatar pendant 4 ans
il ne touchait que 300 dollars
américains par mois alors qu'il
travaillait si longue journée par
semaine sous une chaleur torride
au-dessus de 40 degrés l'été
je devais transporter des câbles et les
installer tout allait bien mais après
trois ans j'ai commencé à voir mal à une
jambe l'ouvrier s'est blessé à la jambe
plusieurs parfois mais elle prenait des
antidouleurs pour continuer de
travailler jusqu'à ce qu'il peine à
tenir debout
craignant qu'au Cathares en lui ampute
la jambe il a attendu ses vacances
annuelles pour consulter un médecin ou
n'est pas
les médecins m'ont dit que mes os se
désintégrais qu'ils étaient abîmés dans
toute ma jambe
une chirurgie mais les séquestres en
permanentes le jeune père de famille
n'est plus capable de rester debout
longtemps
selon des chiffres de l’état d'une Népal
chaque année des milliers de
travailleurs reviennent au pays
gravement blessés et près de 10 000
népalais serait mort depuis 2008 sur les
chantiers du Qatar les autres pays du
Golfe et de la Malaisie
[Musique]
font sécher du riz sur le toit de leur
logement la mère de quatre enfants
raconte ce que son mari faisait
Qatar
sa femme n'a jamais cessé d'avoir peur
qui se tue ou se blesse en tombant d'un
échafaudage jamais elle n'a craint qu'il
meurt dans son sommeil
qui avait 35 ans serait mort d'un arrêt
cardiaque ce qui est considéré comme une
mort naturelle cela évite aux autorités
catery donc été sur les causes du décès
et à l'employeur de dédommager la
famille
60% des décès sont ainsi définis comme
des morts naturels cela ne tient pas la
route selon les ONG qui défendent ces
jeunes travailleurs
[Musique]
on a recensé plusieurs cas où des jeunes
morts d'haricardiaque et il est
important de faire plus d'investigation
plusieurs de ces arrêts cardiaques sont
probablement causés par un stress
thermique qui peut être fatale le Qatar
indirectement reconnu le problème en
interdisant le travail de 10 heures à
15h30 durant les mois d'été
[Musique]
n'a rien reçu du Qatar mais il a eu des
compensations de l'assurance et de son
gouvernement ce qui lui a permis
d'ouvrir un comptoir alimentaire
je ne pouvais plus faire de travail
exigeant et je ne pouvais aller nulle
part à cause de la douleur constante
le commerçant ne fait pas assez de
revenus pour payer de bonnes écoles à
ses enfants si ce n'était de son
handicap il retournerait travailler au
Qatar plus de 2000 népalais quitte
chaque jour pour aller travailler dans
un des pays du Golfe la volonté d'offrir
une vie meilleure à leur famille et plus
forte que la peur de mourir sur un
chantier dangereux